nowadays italy is a republic but as many
of you will know it used to be a
monarchy ruled over by the house of
savoy whose role in the unification of
italy its imperial expansion and its
victory in the first world war gave it a
place at the heart of italian identity
but despite its cultural significance
abolished the monarchy was which raises
the question why why was the italian
monarchy scrapped so like most important
events in history this one can be traced
back to a man in a funny hat in this
case benito mussolini as of 1922 italy's
king was victor emmanuel iii who had led
his country through the first world war
and had seen it win international
recognition as a great power after the
war italy's economy had mostly collapsed
which in turn led to the rise of
extremist parties and mussolini was
someone whose party had risen in
popularity and the king was concerned
about a potential civil war which is why
he refused to order the army to deal
with him the king also wanted someone
who could assert absolute authority over
italy and stop it from lurching from
crisis to crisis and as such despite
mussolini's party only having about 20
of seats in the italian parliament the
king appointed him as prime minister
soon after this as you know world war ii
now at first the war was popular because
winning is fun but the ally soon turned
the tide and with the decline of italy's
military fortunes came the decline in
the monarchy's popularity in 1943 when
italy was very much losing victor
emmanuel decided that mussolini had to
go in that he would sign an armistice
with the allies during the closing years
of the war the king was sidelined from
politics by the italian political class
who would come together as a coalition
to ensure the liberation of northern
italy in the end of the war and after
that they would then decide what was to
be done with the monarchy this coalition
had two sides the left-wing parties who
wanted the monarchy abolished and the
right-wing parties who wanted a
constitutional monarchy to continue but
without victor emmanuel when the war was
over public opinion on the monarchy was
divided and in june 1946 there was a
public referendum victor emmanuel had
already surrendered most of his
authority but he didn't want his own
personal unpopularity to kill the
monarchy and so he abdicated on behalf
of his son now king umberto ii the vote
was a close one with the republicans
winning with about 55 percent of the
vote the republican vote was extremely
strong in the industrialized north for
most of the nation's major cities
whereas in the south and in the city of
rome the monarchist vote won out but it
wasn't enough and the government
proclaimed the birth of the italian
republic umberto wasn't happy with this
result and refused to accept it his
advisers and close friends some of whom
were high-ranking members of the
military argued that force could kill a
republic before it began but he declined
this was because he didn't want a civil
war for one he didn't want to repeat the
horrors of the second world war and two
he believed that the allies would have
likely intervened on behalf of the
republicans and so it was hopeless in
the end umberto was exiled from italy
and would live out the rest of his life
in portugal politicians in italy then
worked on creating a new constitution
which importantly outlawed any attempt
to restore the monarchy ever again and
thereafter the italian monarchy was dead
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons james bissonette
kelly money maker mr wolf sky chappelle
jerry lamdin yn hockey marvin cassell
jordan longley gareth turner rod d
martin bugley wuggily captain cydog
spencer lightfoot corso wolf gustav swan
matthew shipley winston k wood robert
wetzel aaron the white marcus arsenal
maggie pakowski anthony beckett alex
schwinn mo the mukwopa coppertone
spinning three plates ben ivinson
charles the first adam stalter and
scottish trekkie